well it happened
the snyder cut is real the internet pipe
dream conspiracy theory
internet fan campaign that would not say
quit zack snyder's justice league
director's cut will be shot
produced and released on hbo max finally
giving fans what they've been clamoring
for
the snyder cut back in 2017 when zack
snyder had to step away from his
directing duties on justice league to
deal with a family tragedy
warner brothers tapped marvel director
joss whedon to finish the shoot
and in doing so completely reshaped the
storyline adding more comedy
and leaving many fans cold with this
drastically new approach
well i know you didn't bring me back
because you like me
i don't ever since the film's lackluster
critical reception
and tepid box office result the fans
have been
railing on the internet to release the
snyder cut going to extreme
lengths to hopefully entice studio execs
to release
or finish the film as snyder had
intended
but while many will rejoice the snyder
cut there are countless examples of fan
service gone wrong or worse placating
the most toxic voices on the internet
and severely damaging creators
brands and the films in the process so
with so much good and bad coming from
fandom influence
it begs the question when did fandom
become such a force in entertainment and
what does that mean for the future of
movie making
first let's break down what we mean when
we say fan service
this is essentially something in a work
of fiction or in a fictional series
which is intentionally added to please
the audience
of that ip this might be as simple as
things like
a beloved video game musical q in the
animated castlevania netflix series
or the captain america winter soldier on
your left call back from the finale of
avengers end game on your left
or the iconic we are the walking
deadline
from amc's the walking dead in the
comics
when lead character rick grimes utters
the line
it re-contextualized the entire series
by stating the walking dead
were in fact the living we are the
walking dead
so when rick said the same famous line
in the show
it was a moment that was anticipated and
rejoiced by the walking dead's most
die-hard fans whether it's a simple line
or an easter egg prop in the background
of a shot
each moment serves the story but more
importantly it gives the fans a little
love tap to say
hey we see you and this is for you
and although these slight nods are
prevalent in modern day franchise
blockbusters
fanservice has been a part of modern
entertainment from the moment people
started recreating books
video games graphic novels and theme
park rides for movies and television
even going back to before the golden age
of hollywood
consider this fun easter egg and gone
with the wind arguably one of the very
first blockbusters
in the film scarlett's first husband
charles hamilton's death certificate
is signed by wade hampton in the book
charles and scarlett have a son wade
hampton hamilton
director victor fleming added this as
just a little nod to the fans of the
book who would have also have noticed
that all of scarlett's children save her
daughter with rhett were written out
fans love it and rave when they like
what's done
adding depth and authenticity to this
property they already adore
but speaking of gone with the wind it
actually brings us to the darker side of
fanservice and where we take a look at
what happens when things go wrong
either in fan perception or in reality
one of the more obvious ways that
studios try to please fans is when
casting characters they loved on the
page
and try as they might studios often
disappoint
but before we talk about how that
happened with gone with the wind
let's talk about one of the earliest
casting controversies in hollywood
history
in 1921 rudolph valentino became the
world's first bonafide silent film
sex symbol with his portrayal of the
sheik
but even back then when his casting was
announced fans of the novel it was based
upon were up in arms they were convinced
that the italian hunk would not pull off
the menacing and seductive chic
they'd been swooning over on the pages
of edith maud hull's novel
and yes much of the nation was
absolutely
livid when vivian lee a brit mind you
was announced to play the american
plantation princess scarlett o'hara and
gone with the wind
in 1939 gone with the wind was an
international bestseller and just about
every
15 to 30 something white american woman
saw herself as the fiery young debutant
great balls of fire don't bother me
anymore don't call me sugar and it was
these same women who were simply
incensed that after an extensive casting
process
which included the likes of lucille ball
joan crawford
betty davis catherine hepburn and lana
turner
lee a crumpet eating tomato
not tomato on the wrong side of the
boston tea party brit
was chosen fans railed against the
choice there were letter writing
campaigns and threats to boycott the
film
but in the end gone with the wind would
go on to become
the greatest commercial and critical hit
of its day
frankly my hair i don't give a damn lee
would be heralded for her performance
and go on to win
one of the eight oscars the film was
awarded but
that was after the premiere the
controversy is mostly forgotten these
days
given all the current controversy around
the film not surprisingly
but that dust up was what director
sharon mcguire used to clap back at
anyone who questioned her choice to cast
a skinny texan
renee zellwigger as the uber british
bridget jones for bridget jones's diary
but just like scarlett our little
bridget was also
perfectly cast today we think of heath
ledger's role in the dark knight as a
reason not to rail against superhero
casting announcements
but lee valentino and ledger show
that sometimes it pays to wait and see
the end result
before rushing to judgment before
actually seeing
a performance of one of their beloved
stories
but you can't really blame fans for
being frustrated
when what they get on the big screen
isn't exactly
what they envisioned in their heads
we've become so accustomed to ordering
up our latest desire
anytime we please when we're told that's
just not how it works
we find it hard to swallow this is why
we struggle
accepting the fact that we can't order
up a live-action hercules remake like a
popeye's chicken sandwich
from postmates but in all seriousness
storytelling is about vision
characters and craft and that isn't
always served
by trying to know what a fan will think
about not giving wolverine yellow tights
or halle berry having a south african
accent
and as these swings and fan sentiment
can severely damage
or boost the earning potential of a
franchise
mistakes have been made and there have
been casualties on both sides
cleaning up the timelines according to
many one of the most egregious examples
of fan indulgence
is the final trilogy of the skywalker
saga
the series kicked off by pleasing fans
and critics alike with the force awakens
and then well then came the polarizing
the last jedi
followed by the movie that tried to give
fans exactly what they thought they
wanted but for many fell short
though the screenwriters of the rise of
skywalker and director jj abrams would
go on to say that they were not trying
to course correct
many of the major plot points either
conflicted with
or retconned the bits of the last jedi
that fans had to cry after the last jedi
fans were livid change.org petitions
were created
boycotts were threatened and some very
ambitious people put forth a campaign
to remake the entire film which begs
another question
why do people care so much about the
story of space samurais
in 2007 patton oswalt penned a very
funny
cutting but surprisingly prescient
article about geek culture
and fandom called wake up geek culture
it's time to die
in it he litigates the idea that geekdom
is no longer underground
the internet has made anyone who wants
to be an expert on something
actually an expert with just the click
of a mouse and ownership is
even more easily achieved i'm a star
wars fan
i'm a trekkie i'm an anime head and in a
few short clicks
you can be because of this more people
have been seduced by the idea that they
own this content as a part of their
identity
sorry to be the bearer of bad news but
disney owns star wars and there's
nothing
we or even george lucas can do about it
we don't own it
but marketing toy t-shirt and
memorabilia companies have
no problem whatsoever feeding our
addiction
to feel like we do i don't know i
thought they look kind of
dashy that's why these same fans and hey
we count ourselves among them
get supremely upset if they feel like
what they love
or more importantly who they are is not
being cared for
in a way that they would hope because
it's a part of them
experts walk away just walk away
oswald said anyone can become an expert
about anything
instantly in the 1980s you couldn't get
up to speed on an entire
genre in a weekend you had to wait month
to month for issues of the watchmen to
come out
we don't agree with oswald's ultimate
proposal that geekdom should get suckier
to combat this
but he made a point that resonates about
the democratization of fandom
and what it is done including the real
harm it is inflicted on some innocent
people
who are just trying to entertain star
wars actor john boyega came out recently
to plainly say
it was an abdication of duty for studios
not to combat
the online harassment women and people
of color face
when fandoms attacked them online in the
end
the creator fandom echo chamber is never
going to stop
but as much as creatives should keep
fans in the front of their mind
they also need the freedom to take risks
to subvert
expectations to cast an australian actor
mostly known for brokeback mountain
as dc's most feared villain to put a
whole new version of spider-man
on screen in an animated style the world
had never seen
to take wolverine and paint him as an
aging down on his luck
nihilist former hero and maybe they
could even kill snoke
with great power comes great
responsibility
we can rejoice in the snyder cut and in
the fact that sonic will come out
without creepy muscles and creepy teeth
but
we can also acknowledge that giving fans
what they
want can be a fraught path and not
always one that leads to the most
incredible movies no matter where you
land on the debate
we can all be superheroes by helping out
to make sure fandom
is welcoming to everyone we can do it
and we must try to do it quickly
do or do not
there is no try okay okay master yoda we
will do
it's the least we can do as your baby is
the best bit of fan service we've had in
a long time
yes we know we know he's not an actual
baby
you